jyllian or yellow vests refers to the
neon vests that all French drivers must
keep in their vehicles for breakdown
emergencies but now it's come to
symbolize a protest movement frustrated
with French president Emmanuel macron
who they say is disconnected from the
day-to-day economic difficulties
suffered by workers and retirees like
Robert T she must achieve over a a top
tax loss be toward a pool the jaejoong
represent the most serious threat yet to
macarons agenda and his presidency the
movement started off in response to
macros proposal to raise the fuel tax
but now its target is much broader
protesters are seeking to reverse macros
repeal of much of the wealth tax and
many want the President to resign
[Music]
the grassroots asian asian protest
movement surfaced in October 2018
following president macros proposal to
raise fuel taxes to reduce pollution
it began in rural communities where
people depend on cars to make a living
such as circle a private higher driver
bhagavati Babu Newcomb
the chelation movement is strongest in
small cities and towns outside of
France's big metropolitan areas wages
there tend to be low and French taxes
are high in fact the OECD recently said
that France is the most tax Kanna me out
of all of its member countries by
mid-november more than a quarter of a
million people took part in New Zealand
protests and in Paris in December such
events had descended into rioting the
movement which mobilizes through social
media platforms has largely rebuffed the
government's appeals to negotiate
discouraging representatives from
sitting down with officials its appeal
has now broadened to becoming a rallying
cry against the government and what
protesters call a president of the Ridge
Paris residents like rebar mondays say
people have had enough to deport dkc2 sh
t some important me a palapa me arrested
him yet the jail Asia called president
macro president of the rich for a number
of reasons but the most important is his
decision to repeal much of Frances
wealth tax it doesn't help that macro a
former investment banker is himself a
wealthy man the Geale Asian have already
succeeded to some extent of the
president macro delayed his proposed
fuel tax hike and while some protesters
such as Laura cordon yay are optimistic
others like Benjamin Vereen you take a
different view about rising costs Abbas
a verdict Russian gas even more compiler
people deciduous molars postpone a
display
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]